ich habe schon ganz ganz viele
Restaurants in meiner Heimatstadt Köln
gezeigt aber es gibt ein paar die habe
ich bis heute aufgespart meine
Geheimtipps die Läden die ich wirklich
wirklich gerne selbst gehe und dies aus
verschiedenen Gründen nicht in anderen
normale Videos geschafft haben von einem
ladenbus die leckersten ciabatte
außerhalb von Italien gibt über einen
vietnamesisches Restaurant in dem du
dich fühlst wie in einer kleinen T-Stube
bis hin zu einer Vorspeisenplatte die
euch vielleicht bekannt vorkommt aber
nicht bekannt ist
wir stehen hier mitten auf der Straße
und hinter mir seht ihr den Eingang zu
meinem ersten Geheimtipp wir befinden
uns hier am Kölner Großmarkt wo alle
großen Restaurants und so weiter und so
fort einkaufen wo es die größte Qualität
und Frische in ganz Köln gibt auch wir
normales können Einkaufen zwar nicht
überall auf dem Großmarkt aber bei Mara
Atlantico einem delikatessen-händler der
sich so auf Italienisch mediterrane
Küche spezialisiert hat es gibt dort
frischen Fisch in einem eigenen Kühlraum
genauso gibt es fleischspezialität eine
wahnsinnig große Auswahl Gemüse der
höchsten Güte alles was das kulinarische
Herz und das Herz eines Koches begehrt
aber es gibt allen voran ciabatte
[Musik]
guten Appetit Freunde ich sage euch eins
ich fühle mich hier mehr in Italien als
ich mich häufig in Italien gefühlt habe
die Liebe zu den Produkten die hier
gelebt wird die Produkte die zum Einsatz
kommen und die Kunst von den Jungs die
die ciabatte machen ist unerreicht also
wir haben hier mein absolutes favorite
Ciabatta Porta also quasi Porchetta
Spanferkel mit populone Tomate und ich
mache noch immer extra Rucola drauf dazu
so klassischen italienischen Espresso es
erfüllt auf jeden Fall alle
Qualifikationen für einen echten
Geheimtipp und die wichtigste ist dass
es unfassbar gut schmeckt
das lebt halt einfach von den Zutaten
und alles daran ist perfekt der
Provolone der so perfekt schmilz frische
Tomaten das knusprige Ciabatta mit
diesem Maismehl was so ein leicht gelbe
Farbe hat die parketta die so richtig
schön intensiv kräftig schmeckt und der
Crunch so der das einfach so zu einer
wirklichen Freude beim Essen macht 5,50
€ vorgemerkt ne das macht das Ganze ja
auch zum Geheimtipp so weil das hat mehr
Substanz als so ein foot long Subway
Sandwich Gefühl so du bist richtig satt
danach ihr müsst wissen Eric und ich
sind teilweise einmal die Woche hier
einkaufen für unsere Videos und wir
schaffen es eigentlich nie nicht auch so
eins zu essen das kriegt man wenn
überhaupt eine Italien und dort ganz
ganz häufig auch nicht so gut ich lebe
dafür das ist alles für mich
Freunde wir stehen vor dem nächsten
Laden Kaffee 1980 ein vietnamesisches
Restaurant nämlich Kaffee gibt und Bunny
nur diese drei Sachen und
dementsprechend ihr kennt das wie so oft
sind die besonders besonders gut fördern
vietnamesische Nationalgericht
reichsbahnnudeln Brühe Kalbsbäckchen und
all das in einem extrem authentischen
kleinen gemütlichen laden ein Spot bei
dem wir im letzten Jahr noch ganz ganz
ganz häufig waren weil unser altes Büro
nur 30 Meter von hier entfernt ist umso
mehr freue ich mich heute noch mal da zu
sein ich werde es genießen schauen wir
uns an
[Musik]
hier ist sie also die
ist hoffentlich richtig ausgesprochen
das vietnamesische Nationalgericht die
sieht vielleicht unscheinbar aus auf den
ersten Blick wir haben eine klare Brühe
Rinderbrühe darin so ein paar Einlagen
werden Rindfleisch wir haben
Frühlingszwiebeln Teil Basilikum
Koriander alles was das Herz begehrt
unten drin sind noch reichsbandnudeln
und wir fahren noch nicht kennt der
checkt das ganze vielleicht noch nicht
das ist ein sehr sehr guttunendes
Gericht finde ich also man ist das man
fühlt sich dann auch besser als davor
das ist so ein Ding so man kriegt Kraft
davon so es war in der Nähe vom Neumarkt
aber hier außenrum ist eigentlich nichts
wo Touristen sich hin verlaufen würden
dementsprechend ist es auch ein
Geheimtipp so weil sich einfach abseits
der normalen Wege befindet und
gleichzeitig halt wirklich eine sehr
sehr gute Variante von der First und
auch das hier gehört einfach dazu man
kriegt so diese klassischen Soßen
Flaschen mit Soße Chilisauce ich nehme
mir sowas von dem beef
von der Häuschen Soße drauf ist auch
nice wenn das so rein tropft weil das
aromatisiert die Suppe noch weiter
und das ist super Chart richtig lecker
ich habe viel Feuer gegessen aber auch
schon bestellt in Restaurants und so die
ist schon wirklich sehr sehr sehr gut
gerade wenn man irgendwie so im Winter
so ein bisschen am kränkel ist aber so
haut man sich ja so extra viel Chili
rein und danach ist man wirklich wie neu
geboren und das wichtigste ist natürlich
die Brühe
und die ist schön
sie ist so stark dass mir meine Stimme
genommen hat und die ist einfach
gamechanger so richtig so herzhaft
kräftig man sieht auch so diese ganzen
kleinen Fettaugen oben drauf das einfach
so muss es sein
Teller ist leer zweiter geheimspot
wieder mal Baum muss schon mal selbst
auf die Schulter klopfen aber auch der
dritte Spot steht den anderen um nichts
nach deshalb ab zum dritten Spot gewusst
nur Vorspeisen wird
kommen wir zu meinem dritten Geheimtipp
glaube ich hatte lange nicht so viel
Spaß an einem Drehtag wie heute es wird
wieder unfassbar lecker und es gibt
Vorspeisen ihr kennt vielleicht sowas
wie Eis geht immer oder ich könnte immer
Nachtisch essen ich kann manchmal nur
Vorspeise Essen und zwar wenn ich bei
Rossi cheria Massimo bin ihr kennt den
Laden vielleicht ich war schon mal dort
und habe glaube ich eine Pasta gegessen
alles schön und gut ich habe
herausgefunden der Ware Tipp sind die
Vorspeisen ganz kleiner rustikaler Laden
hier in der Kölner Südstadt schon fast
so ein bisschen Bistro Charakter im
Sommer blüht der Laden auf die
Außenterrasse lebt und das wirklich sehr
sehr leckere Essen kommen aus der Küche
zum Tisch und so jetzt auch eine
unvergleichliche Vorspeisenplatte
gemischter Vorspeisenteller das macht
glaube ich immer Spaß zu essen und
schmeckt vor allem auch gut wenn er gut
zubereitet ist hier haben wir vitello
tonnato wirklich mit so einer
wunderbaren Thunfischcreme Würfel
Mozzarella Tomaten Rucola in der Mitte
haben wir panzanella so ein
Kartoffelsalat gegrilltes Gemüse
Carpaccio wieder mit Rucola und der
geheime Star der Show
Focaccia frisch gebacken so eine ganz
besondere Art weil es hat schon fast ein
bisschen was von Pizzabrot ist aber
Focaccia und der ein oder andere denkt
sich vielleicht im Moment mal wie kann
das ein Geheimtipp sein ihr wartet schon
mal hier der Geheimtipp ist das zu
bestellen die Vorspeisenplatte ich
verstehe jeden der jetzt gerade denkt er
was labert der weil sowas habt ihr
vielleicht auch schon mal gesehen aber
das Besondere hier ist dass jedes
einzelne Bestandteil krass ist geistig
krank krass so man kennt das vielleicht
so dass man bei irgendeiner
Vorspeisenplatte so ein zwei Sachen mag
ein zwei Sachen liegen lässt
nicht hier und allen voran lässt man das
hier nicht liegen das Brot ich muss es
sagen es ist eine 12 von 10 es ist
wirklich einfach
den kriegt man eigentlich fast immer
sogar so aufs Haus als Vorspeise hier
dazu
so ein einfacher Kartoffelsalat trotzdem
super lecker und schön cremig Kartoffeln
dann trotzdem noch bis Fenchel drin was
ganz anderes als der klassische deutsche
Kartoffelsalat aber super lecker auch
hier Mozzarella spricht natürlich die
Qualität der gekauften Zutaten
wunderbar Focaccia es hat auch so eine
ganz besondere Konsistenz einfach ne so
ein ganz prägnanten Knoblauchgeruch weil
das wahrscheinlich so ein Knoblauchöl
ist was hier drauf machen die Konsistenz
ist auch wirklich special super soft das
ganze und die Konsistenz ist auch so die
verändert sich so minütlich die kommt
wirklich frisch aus dem Backofen an den
Tisch wenn du die dann auch nicht
schnell ist dann
hast du auch Pech irgendwann vitello
tonnato für mich so ein absolutes
kindheitsding meine Mama hat immer
wieder Telefonate gemacht und jetzt
immer große Mühe dabei gegeben umso mehr
zählt meine Meinung dass das hier
wirklich sehr sehr gut ist
krass das Kalb super Reich regelmäßig
guck mal was was kann Grillgemüse sein
aber man sieht richtig schön viel Farbe
dran es hat trotzdem noch bis
kennst du das wenn so eine
Vorspeisenplatte so einfach nur ein
hängeklatschte Variation von
verschiedenen Dingen ist und das hier
ist einfach so alles davon ist auch ein
Highlight alles davon willst du so
einzeln bestellen aber dass du alles
gleichzeitig hast es umso geiler ich
habe gerade ein bisschen Sorge dass das
vielleicht nicht so sehr rüberkommt so
aber ihr müsst wissen mit wem ich hier
war der das gegessen hat die meinen so
ich hätte auch nur das Essen können
Vorspeisenplatte für zwei Personen ist
auch ein abendfüllendes mal für eine
Person nur noch so überzeugt euch
einfach wirklich mal selbst kommt hier
hin ist das und schreibt dann in die
Kommentare dass es nicht geschmeckt hat
könnt ihr nicht wow jetzt habe ich so
eine Focaccia Pizza
hier gibt's ganz viel leckeres Essen
aber das muss man erleben
und damit Leute verabschiede ich mich
vom letzten Spot vertraut mir alles was
ich euch heute gezeigt habe kommt vom
Herzen das sind alles besondere Läden
für mich besondere Spots die es aus
verschiedenen Gründen vielleicht nicht
in andere Videos geschafft haben die
aber allesamten Besuch wert sind und ich
liebe sie alle deshalb lasst Euch
schmecken wenn ihr sie testet ich hoffe
ihr hattet Spaß mit dem Video bis zum
nächsten Mal Ciao wir hatten auf jeden
Fall auch Spaß